What's up guys
We are Pongfinity
Today we'll be playing table tennis
on an X-shaped table
First I'll try to play against Emil
And then lets do 2 vs 1 against Miikka
Where are you going?
Wrong way apparently
Volley, does it count?
Yeah that's perfecly legal in X table tennis
Not really a wise tactic to hit there
That's the special shot!
Inside out backhand with the edge
Now let's team up against Miikka
I think we are gonna see some running in this match
Good try though!
I'm gonna get this match!
Yes! I found the spot!
That's an evil strategy
I feel a bit like a third wheel here
Very nice running!
Did it touch?
I think it touched
Sorry!
This is impossible
But show me some support by subscribing to the channel
I went for the double bounce
That would have been pretty sick!
Funny experiment for me and Otto!
That was a bit unfair!
We really enjoyed that one
Remember to hit subscribe
and check our previous videos there
Until next time!